The following content is
provided under a creative
commons license.
Your support will help mit
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu
PROFESSOR NELSON: So last time
we just about finished up the
discussion of thermochemisty,
and we went through a
description of calorimetry,
how we actually make
measurements of thermodynamic
a quantities.
I should mention, which I didn't
last time, that you
know a calorimeter, apart from
measuring heats of formation
also is used to measure
standard thermodynamic
quantities like heat
capacities.
You know how much heat does it
take to raise the temperature
of something by a degree?
Well, you put the material
inside the calorimeter, and
you have a heater and it's
connected up to current
source, and you can accurately
measure how much heat you're
putting in, because you can
measure how much current is
going into it, and you
separately are measuring the
temperature of the material, so
it's a straightforward way
of measuring the heat
capacities, thermodynamic data
of this sort.
So work on phase transitions,
just ordinary
properties of material.
Chemical reactions, all the
thermochemistry involved is
done using constant pressure or
constant volume calorimetry
in a pretty routine way.
So we talked about how to use
the results of measurements
like that to calculate
reaction energetics,
enthalpies of reaction.
And I just want to end the unit
on thermochemistry with a
real brief discussion of an
approximate way of formulating
heats of reaction, and that is
in terms of bond energies.
Now you know you're probably
never going to sit down and do
a series of thermodynamic
calculations using bond energies.
You could always look up heats
of formation of compounds and
from those determine very
accurately heats of reaction,
by looking at the heats of
formation of products and the
heats of formation
of the reactants
and subtracting them.
And since that data is available
for a really wide
range of materials, that's sort
of the simplest approach
and the most accurate one to
determine reaction energetics.
On the other hand, if you just
want to think about molecules,
you know, you think
about bonds.
You know if you say I've got
methane or ethane, I'm going
to use a fuel and burn it
and capture the energy.
How much energy do
we have in there?
Well the way you want to be
thinking about that is all
right, I'm going to take the
starting material, the fuel,
I'm going to break bonds, and
I'm going to form some final
product with new bonds.
Roughly what kinds
of energetics
are we talking about?
In biological systems, it's
also super important.
You know you think about
ordinary biochemical
energetics, what's used is fuel
in biology and what are
the products that are formed?
And again, it's just super
important to be able to think
sort of semi-quantitatively
in terms of bond energies,
because you don't want to always
be going and looking up
everything in tables.
If you need to do an extensive
series of calculations, it's
very useful to have
the tables.
But if you just want to think
about how something is
working, you know biological
or system or an engine or
another application, it's very
useful to just be able to
think in terms of
bond energies.
So let's just go over
And you've seen this in 5.111
and 2, so I'm not going to
belabor it but they're just a
little bit of examples that I
want to go through, just so
it's fresh on your mind.
So the idea, of course, is to be
able to have an idea of how
much energy is involved
in forming or
breaking a single bond.
So, if we just do this by
example, we can take methane
so it's a real simple case
because we know it's just got
four identical carbon hydrogen
bonds, and we could say OK,
let's just break them.
So we'll start with methane
gas and go to one atom of
carbon in the gas phase,
plus four atoms of
hydrogen in the gas phase.
The energetics in this case
aren't given by the usual
heats of formation.
You'd just say, if I want to
know about methane, I can look
up its heat of formation from
the elements in their
standards states. but the
difference here is these
elements aren't in their
standard states.
Carbon in its standard state
at room temperature and
pressure is graphite, a solid,
it's not carbon atoms in the
gas phase, and hydrogen in the
standard state is hydrogen
molecules H2, not individual
atoms.
All right, so we'd like to
have this bond energy for
these things.
So let's just to make a cycle
that will allow us to
determine this.
So this'll be our first step in
that cycle, or one way of
getting there.
And this delta H of reaction is
going to be by definition
four times our bond energy for
a carbon hydrogen bond.
Now let's go to be elements that
are in their standards
states at room temperature
and pressure.
So let's go to carbon
as graphite.
And let's go to two molecules of
hydrogen gas, so this will
be step two and this
will be step three.
And this will allow us to work
because now we're starting in
standard states, so
we can just use
regular heats of formation.
And that's the key.
So if we look at step one
delta H1 there as we've
defined it, four times
our bond energy.
Two, this is just negative heat
of formation of methane,
which we can look up.
And three, is similar.
Essentially it's the heat of
formation of carbon in the gas
phase and hydrogen atoms in the
gas phase, commonly called
heats of atomization, but these
are also tabulated just
like heats of formation
of ordinary compounds.
In fact, in the appendix
to your book that has
thermodynamic data, you can find
carbon gas phase atoms
including heat of formation,
and same with individual
hydrogen atom as opposed
to hydrogen
molecules in the gas phase.
So those data are available.
So we can write delta Hc from
atomization, and two times
delta H of H2.
This is the way this is
tabulated and this is molar.
And of course now we've
written a cycle.
So we know that to get from here
to here is the same as to
go through these two steps.
In other words delta H1 is the
sum of delta H2 and delta H3.
And so this says that our four
times the carbon hydrogen bond
energy is just given by minus
the heat of formation of
methane plus the heat of
atomization of carbon, plus
the two times the heat
of atomization
for hydrogen molecules.
And if we look up the numbers
that are tabulated, what we
discover is that our carbon
hydrogen bond energy is 416.2
kilojoules per mole.
Very useful to have numbers like
that stored in your head.
To have some basic idea of
just ordinary chemical
energetics in terms
of bond energies.
Hydrogen bonds, you know roughly
20 kilojoules per
mole, and so forth.
Just having those kinds of
energetic enables you to think
in a qualitative way about
what's likely to happen in an
ordinary chemical or biochemical
situation.
OK, so this is in a sense the
simplest case, because we've
talked about the dissociation of
a molecule that consists of
all identical bonds.
But it's straightforward
to go from there to
additional bond energies.
So from this we've got a value
for a sort of typical carbon
hydrogen bond, right.
We can do the same thing now for
ethane, and that's got a
single carbon carbon bond, as
well as a bunch of carbon
hydrogen bonds, but now the we
know the carbon hydrogen bond
energy, we can use that number
plus the relevant heats of
formation to determine the
carbon carbon bond energy.
And we can keep going and extend
this to essentially
tabulate bond energies for a
very large number of different
sorts of bonds.
So just as an example, ethane,
so now we're going to have --
this I'll write it all out just
some we can keep proper
track of all the bonds that
we're going to be breaking.
So C2H6 goes to two carbon
gas phase atoms, and
six hydrogen atoms.
So in this case, our, I can
write this again as one delta
H1 is six times the carbon
hydrogen bond energy plus the
carbon carbon bond energy that
we'd like to determine.
And again we can go through
now a similar cycle.
So again this now can be
equilibrated with carbon
graphite plus three molecules of
hydrogen in the gas phase,
just like before.
And so from that we can see
that we'll end up with an
equality between these, and
negative delta H naught
formation for C2H6 or ethane,
plus two delta H of carbon
atomization, plus three
delta H for
atomization hydrogen molecule.
So we've already seen we could
look up these numbers and
this, and we've already
determined a carbon hydrogen
bond energy.
So again, if we find all the
relevant values, we can
determine that our carbon carbon
bond energy is 342
kilojoules.
And so on.
So we can keep going and again
build up a bigger and bigger
inventory of bond energies just
to provide us with the
kind of intuition that we'd
like to have to be able to
think about ordinary molecular
energetics.
Any questions about
bond energies?
All right.
Of course, if we know bond
energies, we also could make
estimates of heats
of formation.
So if we have some new compound,
we don't know its
heat of formation, we
know its structure.
We know what bonds
are involved.
We could get an estimate for
what we might expect for its
heat of formation if we know
those, and I think I'll just
write this out on the board by
example, but not work through
the numbers explicitly.
You know, let's say we were
going to make, you know, n
pentane C5H12.
And of course again keeping
proper track of all the carbon
carbon and carbon
hydrogen bonds.
But now in principle we know
the carbon carbon bond
energies and the carbon hydrogen
bond energies.
So we should be able to figure
out the heat of formation of a
compound like this, even if we
don't know it from a table.
And it's again through a similar
sort of cycle so if we
start with the atoms in the gas
phase, and go to n pentane.
So this is now the bond
energies which
we basically know.
And again make our cycle of
involving the elements in
their stable form at standard
temperature and pressure.
Then again, here's our
one, two, three.
Here's our minus delta H of
atomization, and here's our
heat of formation.
And that's the point, is that
now we can use what we've
already elaborated for the bond
energies and the known
enthalpies of atomization,
and we could
determine the heat of formation.
If we do that, we wind up with
a value of minus 152.6
kilojoules.
If we measure it.
If we look up in a table what
the actual value is, we
discover it's minus
146.4 kilojoules.
So it's a few percent off.
Why is it off?
Why isn't it right?
STUDENT: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR NELSON:
Yes, exactly.
You know you can't use the C-H
bonds from methane for every
C-H bond, or the C-C bond in
ethane for every carbon carbon
single bond.
There'll be variations, usually
of modest magnitude,
in the values.
So this isn't going to be an
exact calculation, but
certainly this is close enough
for allowing us to think
qualitatively and
semi-quantitatively about
ordinary energetics.
Another illustration of it is if
we look at neopentane -- so
same chemical formula.
Same number of carbon carbon
and carbon hydrogen bonds.
So according to the way we've
done this calculation, we
should get exactly the same
number, because all we're
doing is adding up the total
number of bonds,
and it's the same.
But what we discover is that
for neopentane, delta H of
formation, neopentane is
minus 166.1 kilojoules.
So again it's different
in this case
in the other direction.
But certainly close enough
that allows us to think
reasonably about what might
happen in ordinary situations.
Any questions about
bond energies?
OK, now we're going to go to a
new topic, and let me say, the
topic we're going to start now,
the second law, is really
in a sense, this is the start of
the whole rest of the term.
So far, what we've covered
essentially is conservation of
energy, how you think about
energetics and what
contributes to them.
That is heat and work.
How to account for them
all properly.
What happens under constant
volume or constant pressure
conditions that led us to the
definition of enthalpy right
and so forth.
And once you get your arms
around these ideas, and it
takes some work to do that, but
once you do, the actual
execution of things can be
pretty straightforward, and
some of this can seem like
just you know a lot of
accounting.
It's not.
It takes some effort to become
accustomed to it and familiar
with how to properly think about
heat and work and how
they contribute to energy
and so forth.
But given that amount of effort,
a lot of this can be
reduced to fairly
straightforward
calculational stuff.
What we're about to start is a
little different from that in
some sense, and really in some
ways more difficult because
what we're going to try to
understand starting with this
next set of topics is what
determines whether something
happens spontaneously?
We haven't really talked about
that in any of this.
We've talked about whether
reactions are endothermic or
exothermic.
But as you're going to see that
doesn't determine what
happens spontaneously.
It certainly is one of the
factors, but by no
means the only one.
What determines what happens
just by itself?
Or another way of saying that
is, if I have some sort of
system, it could be an engine.
It could be a chemical
reaction.
It could be a biochemical system
or some part of it.
What determines where the
equilibrium is and the
direction that things would have
to go in order to reach
or approach the equilibrium?
What is the equilibrium
state of something?
Actually, what we've discussed
so far really doesn't allow us
to determine that, and there are
a few easy ways to sort of
bring that out.
One is you can imagine
constructing some kind of
cyclic process that you know
it could remove heat like a
refrigerator does from a cool
region and export the heat to
a hotter region, like the room,
or outside a window if
it's an air conditioner or
something like that.
Just move the heat.
That's it.
Why not?
I mean you could do that
and not necessarily
violate the first law.
Or what about, here's
a simpler case.
What if I just have a chamber
with a divider, and I pump out
half of it, and I put gas in
this half, so there's gas and
there's vacuum, and then
I remove the divider.
So I certainly expect that what
happens is the gas fills
the volume.
Why?
The first law didn't tell me
that that needs to happen.
Why doesn't it go back the
other way, anyway, even
without the barrier?
Why doesn't the gas just by
itself all wind up over here?
Let's say it's a pretty dilute
gas, so even if it does all
end up in this half, you know
the energy of any sort of
unfavorable repulsions between
molecules is negligible.
Maybe they even have
weak attractions?
Why doesn't that happened?
It's a good thing for us
that it doesn't happen.
Why in this room doesn't the air
all just sort of collect
over there somewhere?
Or just the oxygen molecules
in the air and
suffocate all of us.
The first law doesn't
have anything to
say about that actually.
Whatever the reason it doesn't
happen, we're not going to
find the answer to that
in the first law.
So that's what the second law
of thermodynamics and the
development of entropy
is all about.
It's to help us understand
what is the direction of
spontaneous change?
What governs that, and what's
the equilibrium state that is
reached when the spontaneous
change occurs?
OK?
So the second law is going to
give us basically a principle
that'll tell us the direction
of spontaneous change.
One way of thinking about that
is it's going to allow it to
sort of determine the
direction of time.
You know if we see initial or if
we see one state and we see
another state, we'll be able or
know, time must have been
going this way, right because
the spontaneous change would
happen in this direction.
So, I'm going to put up a couple
of just statements of
the second law of
thermodynamics.
I'll start with kind
of an easy one.
So maybe I'll start
with that here.
Here's a statement
by Clausius.
The first law says that
the energy of
the universe is constant.
We're always conserving
in one way or another.
And the second law is that the
entropy of the universe is
increasing.
Now we're going to define
entropy presently.
But I'm writing this up just to
give you some foreshadowing
of how we're going to try to
guide our thinking about
spontaneous processes.
This tells us about conservation
of energy.
This tells us about which
direction things move in
spontaneously, namely the
direction that leads to an
increase in this soon to be
defined quantity entropy.
It's going to turn out to be a
state function, and it'll help
us understand the direction
of spontaneous change.
You know, like the first law
the second law too was
developed before there was
a very well defined
understanding of the molecular
nature of matter.
We're going to talk about the
second law and entropy in
macroscopic terms.
Later on in the semester we'll
also discuss them in
microscopic terms.
We'll do a little bit of what's
called statistical
mechanics, of microscopic,
basically discussing the
microscopic origins of
entropy in terms
of disorder of molecules.
But really, the thermodynamics
of entropy and the second law
evolved because people were
trying to build things.
It was the Industrial
Revolution. people were trying
to build engines, steam engines,
and other kinds of
devices, refrigerators
other things.
And they couldn't understand --
first of all, why couldn't
you make it perfectly
efficient?
You know, you'd have
a steam engine.
There'd be a source of heat.
You could extract work.
Never seemed like you
could get it all and
turn it all into work.
Why not?
And if not, what were the
limitations on it?
What was the best efficiency
you could achieve?
So in a very practical way
people were motivated to think
very hard about these
kinds of questions.
So let's just look at some of
the things that brought out
the need for this kind
of consideration.
So let me start by drawing one
of the impossibilities.
We could try to build
a heat engine.
Where we've got some temperature
T1 which is hot,
and some amount of heat, q1 goes
into our system, and our
system runs as a cycle.
It goes around and around,
because in any practical
situation we're going to need
to keep going and repeating
the process.
Some amount of work comes out.
We'll call it minus w, because
work is always defined as the
work that's done by the
environment on the system.
So if I'm drawing the arrow this
way, then I want to write
it as minus w.
Now this would be just swell.
This is it.
That's the whole heat engine.
This is running in a cycle.
So we know that, delta
u is zero.
So that would mean that, you
know, the amount of work out
would just equal the heat
in every time around.
Never happens.
Can't make it happen.
The only way it works is
if instead there's
an additional part.
Somewhere heat is also lost
to a cold reservoir.
In other words, you know
I burned some fuel.
I consumed something to produce
my hot source, and I'm
going to then try to turn it
into work, which I can, but
only partly.
There's going to be heat loss
somewhere to a colder region,
and I can't avoid it.
And it was discovered that
this was always the case.
So this can be built where, just
to be clear on these. q1
is a positive number, because
again that's heat going from
the environment to the system.
This is our system running
in a cycle.
So q1 is positive, minus w is
positive, that is work is
being done on the environment
by the engine.
And minus q2 is positive.
And T1 is greater than T2.
That I can build.
Here's another thing
we could try to do.
It's sort of the opposite.
We could try to produce a
refrigerator but not have to
do any work.
So let's go the other way, in
other words, let's go from T2
which is cold we're going to
go in this direction now,
which means q2 will be a
positive number and here's our
system running in a cycle.
And now here's minus q1 now is
going to be our positive
number, and we're going to
remove heat from q2 and move
it, or from T2 a cold region
and move it to some place
that's hotter.
Also a pretty nice idea.
And also obviously impossible.
It only works if I put work in
there to make it happen, then
yes I can take heat out of a
cold body and move it up into
a hotter reservoir
of some sort.
So here's a refrigerator.
Again T1 is greater than T2,
and in this case q2 is
greater than zero.
I'm removing heat, minus q1 is
greater than zero, that is
heat is going up this way.
Work is greater than zero.
Has to be.
Of course the thing is running
in a cycle. delta u is zero.
So that means that work must
be minus q1 plus q2, right?
And work is greater than zero,
so that's saying minus q1
right that's a positive
number, must
be bigger than q2.
In other words, I am taking
some heat away
from the cold region.
The heat I'm dumping into the
hotter region is bigger than
the amount that I taking away
here, because it's also got
this amount.
That's why, you know, if it's
a humid or warm summer
afternoon and you think oh what
I a great idea, I've got
this little fridge in my room.
I'm going to open it up
and cool the room off.
Turns out not to
work too well.
Because of course what
the fridge is
doing, it's cold inside.
So it's a machine that's
removing heat from the inside
and dumping it outside.
There are coils in the back of
the fridge, and if you touch
them they're a little
bit warm and so on.
The heat is being lost
to the room.
How much heat?
Well, the work that goes
in is also added.
So the amount of heat that
goes out into the room is
bigger than the amount of
heat that you're taking
away from the space.
That's bad.
So if you try opening the
refrigerator door to cool off
your room at the same time as
you're dumping heat into your
room, all you discover is
the net effect is to
heat up your room.
Because you know the amount
of heat that the thing is
removing from somewhere on the
inside there and struggling to
do that because you've left the
door to the fridge open,
right, is not as big as the
amount out heat that's coming
out in those coils
on the back.
It's not as big because that
heat has not only the heat
that you're removing from
the inside, but also
this amount of work.
It's all conserved because
delta u is zero.
The thing is running
in a cycle.
Try it sometime.
You can verify this
experimentally in a very
simple way.
It's not a very effective way
to work, and it wastes a
little bit of energy, but
could be worth it in the
interest of knowledge
and discovery.
Let me write an alternate
statement of the
second law of Clausius.
All spontaneous processes
are irreversible.
When I open that panel in the
container, I've got gas on one
side and vacuum in the other
and it expands in there, it
happens spontaneously, and
it's irreversible.
It's not just going
to go back.
And now let me write a
mathematical statement of the
second law.
And we'll celebrate
it's importance
by using this color.
Going around in a cycle, if I
integrate the quantity dq
reversible over T, I get zero.
Remember this, this is
our special function.
Let me just keep going
a little more though.
Let me also write
another version.
If I write dq for an
irreversible path over T,
right, less than zero.
It's not the same.
This is a state function.
This isn't.
Remember of course that the heat
that's exchange between
the system and the environment
depends on the path.
If there is a reversible path,
and you see how much heat was
exchange with the environment,
and you look at that divided
by temperature integrate over
the whole thing, you discover
that as long as the path is
reversible, it only depends on
the states at the beginning
and the end of the path.
In other words if you have
various ways you can go from
state one to two that
are reversible,
it's always the same.
We saw that for just a
couple of examples, a
couple lectures back.
Remember, we looked at these
thermodynamic cycles and just
said, well let's just
calculate those.
And those were, those all
involved reversible processes.
So, in effect, we looked at
different paths to go from one
state to another.
We had a cycle, and one path
went to here, and the other
path went back.
We discovered that, in fact,
this one zero around the cycle
or the way we expressed it at
the time is the value of this
was the same regardless of the
way we got from one state to
the other, whether we took a
straightforward route or a
more circuitous route, as long
as they were reversible.
We're going to define dS as dq
reversible over T, and since
we're dealing with a state
function delta S going from
state one to two of dq
reversible over T is S2 minus
S1 state function.
And S as state function is the
entropy, and of course the us,
it will always be special.
All right, now, the second law,
you know it's difficult
to understand and to get your
arms around, because you know,
do I really calculate this?
I actually have to find a
reversible path in order to do
the calculation.
Normally, you know, when you
calculate delta u and delta h
and so forth, you have various
ways to calculate them that
can be pretty straightforward.
But here, you actually have to
determine the heat exchanged
between the system and the
environment, and you know that
does, in general, depend
on the path.
But it turns out that this
quantity, you know, the
differential of that heat over
the temperature, also depends
on path unless it's
a reversible pass.
Any reversible path will lead
to the same results.
It doesn't depend on path
among reversible paths.
What that means in practice is
if we say OK, start here and
end here and calculate the
entropy, you actually have to
sort of figure out a reversible
way of getting from
here to here so that you can
do that calculation.
So it's really very different
from ordinary functions that
you've been dealing with.
A lot of people, you know,
because the second law is
difficult to understand, you
know you can easily go online
and see thousands of violations
of the second law.
It's still easy to look, to go
find claims of perpetual
motion machines.
Some of them cost
a lot of money.
You can buy them, see
how they work.
But and also, all sorts of
schemes for producing energy.
Go online and see, right.
You're just, they're just crazy
ideas about getting
energy from nothing.
Getting energy from the heat
that's just already
present in the air.
I mean there's heat in the air,
all this motion, it must
have energy.
We should be able to extract
it and use it.
Turns out we can't do that.
It has to look something
like this.
OK.
I want to look at some more
statements of the second law.
To do that I just want to
indicate one definition which
is just to be clear what
these things mean.
These are what I've called
heat reservoirs
or hot or cold bodies.
Here's what I mean to
be more specific.
A heat reservoir is basically
a very large thermal mass at
the same temperature.
And the real idea is that you
can bring heat out of it as
much as you want and the
temperature won't change.
It's an idealization. right If
you have something that's big
enough, and it's at a constant
temperature, of course you can
take heat away, but it's just
so enormous that you won't
measurably change it's
temperature.
In practice you might be able
or approach that limit.
OK, now let's look at some more
definitions or statements
of the second law.
This is from Kelvin of Kelvin
temperature scale fame.
It's impossible to convert heat
into work with a system
that operates in a cycle.
I'm going to write
this all out.
I know you've got it
in your notes too,
but it's super important.
To convert heat into work with
a system that operates in a
cycle, without at the same time
transferring some heat to
a colder reservoir.
OK, a couple of things
to notice.
One is, you know, in some sense
the second law is kind
of negative, right?
Must not have been done
in the new age.
It tells us what we can't do.
And that really is in a sense
what it's all about.
It's telling us what are our
limitations of what can be
accomplished.
Very important part of this
statement -- in a cycle.
Of course any practical engine
has to keep going, so there's
going to be a cycle in some
way or another, but it's
important because, you know,
there are some -- if I'm not
operating in a cycle,
I can convert heat
into work just fine.
You know, I could have a heat
source, got a candle, and I've
got a piston, maybe I've
got a weight on it.
I've got something
stopping it.
And then I remove the stoppers
and let it go, and because of
the heat, there's expansion.
It pushes up, right, and it'll
be up higher somewhere.
Worked!
Heat turned into work.
I don't have a cold
body somewhere.
But I only did this once.
There was just one stroke
of the piston.
If I want to continue it and run
in a cycle, somehow I've
got to have a place where
the heat goes.
So this sort of diagram
describes effectively the way
the Kelvin statement works.
This works fine and like we
illustrated before, it doesn't
work fine if I don't have
this part of it.
I won't be able to just take all
the heat and convert it to
work, like I, in principle,
could do, if I don't need to
run it in a cycle.
Here is yet another statement
by Clausius And we'll
end with that one.
Maybe I'll just read
this one, so we can
not go over the time.
So, it's impossible for any
system to operate in a cycle
that takes heat from a colder
reservoir, transfers it to a
hotter reservoir, without at the
same time converting some
work into heat.
In other words, it's a statement
kind of similar to
the Kelvin statement, but
applying to the case of moving
heat from a colder to
a hotter region.
Can't do it, unless some work is
also converted to the heat
that gets released into
the hot region.
I think we'll stop there.
Next time what we'll do is lay
out a very well-defined kind
of engine called Carnot cycle
that allows us to very
explicitly go through and say
OK, let's just work out the
steps of isothermal and
adiabatic expansions and
contractions.
In other words, how does
the engine really work?
And just calculate it going
around in a cycle and see
exactly how all this
is born out.
And we'll see that next time.